within this project we find 16
susceptible genes for lupus for the
Chinese population use polygenic risk
score and machine learning to do the
prediction to do the prediction of the
disease for different for fo for the
specific population because we cannot
use the genetic data of European
population to predicted disease in
Chinese population know someone's
opinion may contradict yours what is my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we and what is the
nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Sathyan we are on
site in the beautiful Westlake
University in Hangzhou China we are now
going to be talking about Chinese
population genetics we have dr. hall
Fung joining us on the show yeah yeah
thank you
they didn't so much for being on our
show yeah thank you I'm so excited it
was great getting a nice tour of your
lab in which you guys are working on
here Congrats on all the progress those
that don't know ho Fong Jung is
principal investigator at Westlake
University researching bioinformatics
tools for the analysis of large genetic
data and complex disease and you can
find the links in the bio all right
let's start things off with one of our
favorite questions we like asking our
guests okay what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world the direction
of our world yeah this question is too
hard to answer I think as a scientist
what we want to think out is how human
come from and how we
we're gold I think is such a big
question we want we would like to become
right not only on the nature but also on
the the Society of the humanity I think
yes yeah I I don't have her addictive
answer where did our campus LeBron where
are we going
yeah this is discussion is so big I love
the question yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
will always wonder what are some of the
main principles that we can embody to
help us
yeah sure that it's going in a positive
direction right well what do you think
may be one of the key principles yes
may be in nature selection I I do
research on complex disease right you
know so the develop of complex disease
can be explained by a nature selection
oh one kind of nature selection that's
let's negative selection hmm yeah yeah
yeah
whoa so something that humans can
potentially do is try and move further
away from negative selection where there
may be some of the things that cost
suffering or disease or things like this
and we can maybe move ourselves more in
a direction of flourishing away from the
complex disease which is some of the
stuff that you're trying to do is yeah
help us heal help us eradicate things
like osteoporosis are these types of
things yeah yeah yeah let's talk about
the journey
so who were you as a kid and how did you
get interested in genetics and science
you mean who make me feel interested in
genetics or science I think it's it's a
long story and you know my actually my
father he picked this he helped me to
choose my major when I finished my high
school and he expect me to be a doctor
and actually I made on the clinical
medicine and I think I finished my MD
degree in China and but after my MD
degree I didn't actually become a doctor
I choose to do research because I at
that time I did research on genetics of
skin disease like Lotus and after my PhD
I continued to do genetics but not on
skin disease but under the boom this is
bone health
yes like osmosis yes yes so let's talk
about you know as you find yourself
getting more and more interested in you
know in clinical medicine and then in
population genetics and in
in helping people with disease you made
some pretty serious discoveries along
the way mm-hmm in in the MD was from a
benzyl Medical University and CEO sandal
University stand oom provinces and do
problems in north of China of China yeah
and then the PhD was from Anhui Medical
universe yes okay and let's talk about
the first discovery so we have several
these discoveries that we're gonna talk
about this one was about susceptibility
genes for systemic lupus yeah and you
did this by a genome-wide study in China
right so teach us about how you're
finding this so forget about we to find
this in order to find the susceptible
genes of Lopez we need a a group of
cases patients and a group of conchos
house house individuals - and to compare
the allele frequency of these two groups
if a snip have a worried different a
little worried different allele
frequency between these two groups we
hypes us that list nip is associated
with the disease yeah and within this
project we find 16 susceptible genes for
lupus for the Chinese population Wow yes
okay so you're given a population wide
genetic database and you work how many
samples were in this one maybe couple
how many samples
you mean this project the Lucas project
I think is 3000 3000 yeah we see you
3000 and some so some of them have lupus
yes some of them have lupus almost a
thousand had yeah and 2,000 did not yeah
and then what you were doing was you
were looking at how did you find the you
said 14 G 1660 yeah jeans okay 16 jeans
had the strongest susceptibility to
having a snip in them which is a which
is a variant in the genetic code so an
allele to two alleles for one snip yeah
and how did you identify these 16 genes
we yeah you know that in in the whole
genome genotype typing data we have less
than a million snips right and we test
least 1 million snip one by one tested
the association with the disease one by
one and find 16 not exact 16 because the
snips they have LD that means one snip
it one snippet exist then a not snip
where exist together let's LD but least
16 snip their independent snip there
have no LD each other with each other
yeah okay yeah and then suddenly you
find out these areas of variants that
are similar for people with lupus
and that people without lupus the other
2,000 don't have the same variance that
the ones of lupus do in those 16 genes
actually is the frequency difference
between cases and controls yeah okay
yeah frequency different the frequency
allele frequency difference yes actually
in conchos they also have the allele but
the frequency will be much lower in
cases the frequency were much higher
yeah let let lets let's the snip the
snip means the snippety that means that
it not it didn't means it didn't exist
in controls it did exist in controls by
the allele frequency much lower yeah
okay so the allele difference the low
frequency difference in the Lupus was
higher right okay okay and lower in
control that you have lupus okay okay
interesting okay and then so then then
it was our arm curious for other
discoveries as well is allele frequency
difference a pretty good indicator of
what a potentially a discovery of a
variant and the disease is yes that's
what we want to say that the ally of
allele frequency difference between
cases and controls is a pretty good
biomarker yeah yeah it's a biomarker
yeah one of the top biomarkers is allele
frequency difference right so when you
get yeah x-ray the snip is the by mark
the snip is the bottom
yes and there's a there's a greater
frequency of snips in patients with
lupus yeah in this case yeah so for all
of us that are getting our genome
sequenced that we're we we want the some
of the things that we want to care about
is our our allele frequency difference
we want to that's that's something
that's a big biomarker for okay yeah
that's what we want to see let's let's
let's we let's we how we choose the
snips how we choose the snips we choose
the snips with very different allele
frequency between cases and to choose
let's we choose these 16 snips they have
what it different or the frequency
difference okay yeah
so there's 16 specific snips that had
the greatest allele frequency difference
yes okay and then you hypothesized that
those were the 16 snips that were
related to the difference between
healthy patients and lupus but yes and
it was direct right yeah like cool cool
okay okay okay
so so then it could potentially be that
identifying snips in genomes and looking
at allele frequency differences between
healthy populations and the disease's
population this is one of the biggest
ways to identify disease right yeah
okay and was now what were you doing in
this next discovery discovering the
north-south population structure of
Chinese hum population what is tell us
about this in this project we include
samples from ten different Chinese
population ten to ten Chinese publish
province provinces distributed from
north to south we select ten province
from source to nose and to see the
population structure the population
structure differences between these ten
provinces and we we we discovered that
there are two dimension distribution of
the genetic structure yeah let's that
means you know in noise from Leonie
let's a province from North East from
longing to send doom them to search on
them to quantum the geography can proxy
the genetic structure okay
again you had a sample oh yeah how large
was this sample of joy it's six thousand
six thousand six thousand from this ten
provinces yes and five were in the north
and five were in the south or I think
yes also they have six thousand then I
think is two thousand from those two
thousand from sauce and also two
thousand from middle-middle
yeah interesting yeah okay and then when
you were analyzing the genetics of those
six thousand what were you looking for
to determine the difference between
North and South Han Chinese because we
we have already done the whole genome
genotyping and this can provide the
information of all the genetic
information of all these samples and we
we we conduct our analysis called
principal component analysis this can
identify the genetic component of the
populations of the samples a principal
component analysis yeah
principal component analysis that's PCA
CA yeah it can identify the the specific
genetic differences between yeah because
we can use the principal component to
the value of the principal component to
compare the values of these samples okay
okay yeah okay and and the the big the
big difference is that you said there
was some sort of a of a distribution
between the clear distribution between
who was south yeah yeah yeah yes yes if
we have a one big reference we we have
in videos from each province and the
sample sizes it picked them we can build
a list kind of reference yes and a new
one come come here we can sequence them
and to say which province if yeah yeah
yeah and then there was a postdoc that
you were doing at McGill University that
was in human genetics night and when you
were doing that for years you made
another discovery in 2012 to discover
the susceptible genes for osteoporosis
yes okay and this was fracture and
thickness of bone in the Caucasian yes
okay so explain this one to us as well
it's it's it's Australis is related a
trait are related the disease right the
final outcome of osteoporosis is
fractured yeah
so the stress the stress T G is the same
as what we have done for the skin
disease we also the design is also the
same a group of cases and a group of
conscience and to say the earlier
frequency difference and for this
project why this list project published
in nature because we find that the rare
genetic variant because in in the rare
genetic variant is hard to find because
they are rare
you know in for example in 1000 simples
maybe the mutation only present in only
one in videos so it's world where it's
hard to find so we find the rare genetic
variant for oast proces yes
yeah how out of a thousand samples are
you able to find just one of the rare
genetic mutations this just example yeah
actually it's not only one maybe several
okay yeah because we do the genotyping
we do the sequencing and genotyping we
know the the jet the we know the allele
of each individual you know the ally of
each Avenue in Windows yeah and then you
find and then you know the ones that
have osteoporosis and you see which a
wheel variants yeah rare genetic variant
the rare genetic variants associated
with osteoporosis yeah
and in versus the rest of people don't
have that right and so then you're able
to target that and say that that's
probably the Ryan and who I maybe look
at other people with osteoporosis and
see that they have the same like okay
like okay okay so then in 2015 these
have these kind of did this happen at
the same time the one thousand talents
program by the Chinese government and
also the the UK 10k project which one
happened first the UK 10k pressure yeah
because the UK take a project they start
from this study from 2010 and finished
in 2015 so we published this paper in
2015 yeah okay
and then in that UK 10k project in 2015
you found the rare variants for bone
mineral density yes okay so you were
teaching me about this bones are made of
calcium but when I'm in a ravine bone
marrow
yes mineral is made of calcium yes and
then there's bone marrow inside that we
were
about as well yeah belief has a lot of
the stem cells yes right okay so like
the bone mineral density and this is in
grams per square centimeter yes if it's
too low you have higher propensity for
our osteoporosis yes high defection and
fracture yeah which leads to fracture
yeah yeah bone weakness
yes needs to fracture this yeah so how
did you find out that that this density
of bone mineral was that you could
figure out based on genetics density of
bone minerals yes because yes oh no you
got some minor dents they have a very
high heritability
it's about from 15 percent to 85 percent
50 to 85 percent yeah yeah of
heritability that means 50 percent to 85
percent of the boom my my neural density
variation can be determined by genetics
yeah but of course it's also influenced
by by by the my environmental factors
yeah so so the answer is yes oh no okay
so then you were identifying in this you
K 10 K project-specific is it again a
allele variance yes yes for osteoporosis
yes bone mineral density being right
okay okay became the professor at Hanzo
Normal University for two years in 2015
2017 and what were you doing when you
were there
teaching genetics part of my job is
teaching also research work and research
yeah and base as well your papers have
been cited three thousand four hundred
times that's massive yeah it's a lot of
citations yeah that's the total citation
of myattís yeah yeah yeah so cool and
then Westlake University in March 2017
so you've been here over two years now
like and you've been approaching two and
a half yeah that's really cool it's now
two and a half yeah yes and so and this
has been slow growth process of
acquiring now ten lab members there's
seven PhD students working at the lab
yes and now this is gonna be this deep
dive there's so much cool stuff here so
bioinformatic tools for the analysis of
large genetic data and complex disease
cells you were teaching me about this
you said that right now we have this
issue with genetics where most of the
whole genome sequences in the world are
Europeans yes and so the the reference
that we have of these 30 million
variants are are made for analyzing
European yes yes so there's this idea of
genetics for all right where you can
have like you have 1.4 billion people in
China another one point almost 4 and
India and you know so the idea is that
can you make a a whole genome sequence
reference of these 30 million variants
for Chinese people
yeah and for Indian people and for all
these different countries in the world
yeah so it's not just for European yeah
well I like I love this so then you had
this idea of having the West Lake bio
bank for Chinese WB BC right so teach us
about why you're doing W B BC where you
guys are at
teachers about it yeah just like you
said that most of the genetic data
now generally generated most of them are
on the European populations so if we
would like to do a prediction of disease
we need to derive the effect from the
specific populations like if we want to
predict disease for Chinese population
we need to derive the effect from
Chinese population so we that's why we
want to do this Weslake by bank for
Chinese to list by bank can be can
produce a lot of data and to produce a
lot of effect which can used to predict
the disease I think yes okay so as we
have more of these bio banks happening
for different countries around the world
you guys hopefully going deeper into the
Chinese bio Bank then we can better
understand the formation of complex
disease and we can help people live
healthier yes your lives
yeah yeah okay so we're yeah let's talk
about where you guys are at with that so
you've had you you're working with
universities yes and so universities are
are the blood samples from University
yes do you guys take two there do you
guys take the blood samples a sequence
at yourselves or do they sequence it and
give you the data
how does yeah we take those samples and
we sent out to companies they helped us
to sequence them and they return the
data to us
yeah okay so the University the blood
from the universities goes to the
company sequencing companies which they
give you by data and then when you guys
you have how many total sequences four
thousand five hundred plus the six
thousand to teach us about the total
rewrite it's about ten K by ten thousand
yeah yeah and four and a half thousand a
whole genome sequenced and then six
thousand or whole genome genotype yeah
okay
and then now how are you then studying
the genetics of bone mineral density in
this sample that you have so you're
looking for the allele variance of
osteoporosis yes okay yes so the stretch
to suggest digit is a little different
from my previous study in this study we
didn't care about which gene it's
associated with the disease we use the
whole genome data to to do the
prediction then we use the machine
learning method to do this prediction
also the polygenic risk score yes use
polygenic risk score and machine
learning to do the prediction okay okay
so when you talk about polygenic risk
score and machine learning applied to
whole genome sequencing what do you find
that gives you the understanding of
osteoporosis in fact these protests
they're ongoing
yes right I just start my
the laboratory in Westlake for two years
yes and it'd take me a lot of a lot of
time to collect all these samples and we
just start this project hope hopefully
we can get where it could be thoughts to
help to predict the auspices for the
Chinese population yes yes I love the
big vision that you have with it and
this is one of the things about science
and it needing to be better well funded
and also have more world-class research
places like Wesley pop up because then
you can have more scientists that are
doing these long processes that take
time that they have to have better
computational resources and better
genetic data bank resources and all this
type of stuff to help you guys move the
pace faster in scientific discovery okay
so one out of every thousand references
variants that we have is genetic
variants one out of every thousand
genetic variants that we have is going
to be some sort of a potential formation
of maybe a disease maybe yeah it's
possible yes okay okay so you can be
more susceptible to developing the
disease but not developing right yeah
you're right yeah yeah okay okay so I
can have a high allele frequency
difference and be susceptible to
developing the disease but not device
yes so then it's okay to have in a
health some people in the healthy
population have high amounts of variants
but they don't develop the disease yes
okay and then there are other people
that yeah because this list is a
probability to probability and this is
disease yeah
they least people who carry this allele
they are moms step low to the gene to
the disease but maybe he he didn't
develop developing this disease at the
end o they die before they develop this
disease yeah yeah I have let's say
allele variance that gives me maybe a
20% probability to develop a disease
yeah it's like one in five it's a little
bit lower so I don't have it
yeah but you could go the other way and
say that loops this fifth person got it
the disease because they yeah yeah you
can happen you can have different
variants of probability probability yes
that's why we would like to do the
prediction the prediction also a
probability so if if a person who have
at a high or susceptible to the disease
then we for example post-process then we
can do the intervention of these
patients or individuals yes to to
prevent the final outcome yes like let's
talk about the interventions because if
I do have the allele variance and a high
probability of developing a complex
disease what are some of the best things
that are recommended for people right
now for like osteoporosis yeah so for us
truce is this I think the three three
main factors can affect osmosis the
first one the major one is the genetic
effect right we already talked a lot
this second one is the nutrition the
third one is the exercise so
so the genetics now we can we cannot
[Music]
vote for complex disease it had for us
to edit it to edit the genetics the
genome so we can do modify the other two
factors the nutrition and the exercise
yes yeah so then the behavior changes
towards better nutrition and more
exercise can help decrease the
probability of developing osteoporosis
and then also down the line it is
possible that we can go with something
like CRISPR potentially yeah and make
the genetic edit that needs to happen in
order to fix the disease of the
osteoporosis yeah it's because this is a
complex disease this is a complex treat
yeah it's not a single point yeah it's
not a single point where n't
can we're talking yeah yeah dozens yeah
point my experience so if we go and
didn't know that rather than that like I
could go and change all of those there's
potentially effects five years ten years
down the line that we're like oops yeah
that could be the problem
yes yeah this is why biology simulations
are very important because if you can
simulate what doing those who knows
thirty points of eat of change our
forward to make it a healthier
individual without the complex disease
of osteoporosis can you fast for over 20
years and see if the person yeah yeah
okay again do that millions of times to
make sure after Ryder's there okay bye
yeah yeah like these are some of my
favorite things these simulations okay
because hopefully we can get to the
point where
we can do it better and better because
then people can live healthier and yes I
have to experience complex disease right
okay so um also at the lab is a bunch
there's people doing different things
here you have you have people looking at
the genetic variants in the Chinese
population mmm you have a recent study
that was finished on alcohol and blood
pressure yes which I found to be very
interesting there's a very there's a
very specific allele variance for people
that can not get drunk fast and like
that get drunk too fast which is a very
interesting study because then some
people will know it's like why do they
keep drinking one glass of wine and I'm
drunk off yes yeah stuff like that yeah
cuz then you can know that it has to do
with your genetics light it's very
interesting thing and the other ones are
like I drink a whole bottle and I'm fine
yeah why sometimes we yeah it's cool to
know that biology and even something
like allele variance and this was only
at a single point yes it's a single
point yeah yes Wow and for for those
that are really interested its
are s 671 yeah as six that is six seven
one yeah yes for those that are very
interested in that variance is cool and
that was in a sample of 2349 han chinese
yes yes if it's a GG you can drink like
like if we'd say a you're gonna have
trouble with my drinking a lot yeah yeah
okay for myself i already jennifer have
this my is eighty okay so your middle
here yeah i mean the middle but i cannot
drink a lot so yeah and then and there
was also another interesting cultural
aspect to with women where women
generally in China not drinking so much
so a lot of them in this study were yeah
yeah
yeah they had GG for drinking a lot they
weren't drinking any like night yeah and
then another one is doing epidemiology
of peak bone mass of Chinese obviously
so we actually actually we had a we had
a good conversation about this before we
started to the number was the number was
quite high it was that it was 1500 total
mass of skeletal calcium engrams
mm-hmm was 1,500 for men between the
ages of 20 and 40 yes so so basically
the peak bone mass the peak bone mass so
so basically when your child your total
skeletal mass in calcium and grams
increases very fast yes it's all you're
like 20 yeah and then it like Peaks
around that 20 to 40 range for men it's
1,500 grams and for women it's closer to
1,200 grams and then after 40 both men
and women start dropping yes and then
women have a more significant drop
because of menopause yes yes yes I found
this to be so so interesting and because
you were mentioning this earlier too
there's a 50 to 85 percent heritability
light of this mine so it's very likely
that if your if your parents have a
lower amount of total skeletal calcium
mass that you as well will have lower
and so then I was asking you about this
too is like okay so when you're doing
this I mean is it possible that we can
find as you guys are doing this this
dive into the epidemiology of peak bone
mass of Chinese is it possible that you
can find specific variants for people
that have a higher peak bone mass
yeah versus ones that have a lower peak
bone yes yes yes yes let's one of our
design to you know to find the genetic
warrant for the peak bone mass and why
we want to do this is you know most of
the drugs treat on Australis nowadays
they are the drugs trying to slow down
the loss of bone if we can find a gene
or a pathway who which is a determinant
of the peak bone mass maybe we can find
a drug target to increase the bone mass
yeah because most of the judges now they
are their target is to increase the bone
loss yeah to slow down look down the
bone loss yeah yeah interesting so we're
in a sense were fighting the
osteoporosis with trying to slow down
the the bone ma the bone density loss
yes and we could come up with another
solution yeah which is targeting more
bone yeah to increase the bone density
interesting yeah but we have to find the
variance right first light and then we
have to target the drug at those
variants yeah and figure out how to
increase the light interesting so in a
sense there's for probably for a lot of
complex disease there's a couple ways to
handle it yes in many of the ways we
handle complex disease right now is like
how do you take in molecular
that usually affects more than just the
targeted yeah area and it fights it in a
specific way then maybe there's ways
that we can take something that enables
us to fight it in a more optimal way
light so discovering those pathways
though for more optimal combating
complex disease yes yeah yeah yeah like
that
okay so then also using machine learning
to predict the height of Chinese men yes
so then do you do you have any like
ideas about like these these are complex
things like this is not yeah probably
yeah a single right yes this is another
complex shape yeah you know because we
have this population and this population
is at the mean age of 19 and we have the
height measurement we also have weight
and other measurement and we would like
to build a model to predict from
genomics to height and if we have this
model damn new new boom comes out if we
then if we we have the RDA we can
predict the height that there are 19 age
yeah yeah yeah that's really interesting
yeah yeah so yeah and as you get more
and more of the genetic samples you can
have a greater greater accuracy yeah
right of the height like Maya
interesting and height is more likely to
be accurate than weight right yeah like
weight is so wearable variable yeah what
they eat how often they're life-sized
almost kind of stuff
yes but height you're pretty much gonna
end up being that
yeah it's all interesting okay it's
interesting to that for probably for
those that are you know that are
watching that are thinking well there
are likely lots of other scientists
around the world that that watch the
program and especially also you know PhD
students etc yes some postdocs whatnot
that are just trying to figure out how
do i leverage computational power onto
genetic data sets and to find unique
insights mm-hmm and so you know like you
know you guys here if you guys want to
you know come and look for opportunities
Westlake has lots of unique
opportunities where they're looking for
people to do PhDs and postdocs yeah and
be able to join a really powerful
yeah because yes yeah I wonder you know
once we leverage more computational
power on on challenges like this what
unique insights will find like well how
many you know variants determine height
and where are they oh yeah that type of
stuff okay and that's just height that's
one thing then there's you know there's
all of the other well what about you
know this one's really tough but like IQ
that's yeah yeah yeah guys are really
enjoying like yes like is it possible to
you know to predict something like that
but that also determines a lot if you're
sitting there doing like you know too
much thing yeah you had too much
distractive material even if you had a
high propensity for IQ you might have
been lower yeah but it could also be the
opposite where if you read a lot and if
you worked really hard yeah
you end up a little higher - yes yeah
yeah this is this is also interesting to
me leveraging computational power on
genetic data yeah and then okay so also
there's a surname and geography study in
an ancestry and geographies yes yes okay
so what are you guys looking at there we
get us a name from our father right and
we also get our Y chromosome from our
father and so we would like to see a
person who have the same surname of of
me like Zen we I want we want to see how
similar of our genome is patinas if wish
we have the same surname how what - what
proportional of the genome we share
together yeah yes yeah so depending on
your last name if it's the same you may
have a higher no we cannot say that
because for example people with this
name of same like me another people who
have a surname of one but I have more
genetic similarity with that yeah yeah
because these people who name of one he
is my cousin or something then we can we
may share more genetic yeah yeah
interesting point
yeah maybe someone born in your province
near you with a different last name you
have more in common with than someone
with the same last name but from the
south part of China yeah Nordia
something like yeah let's the
interesting thing we want to
dear yeah the research yeah okay and
then I was asking you about this to the
metagenomics in yeah nice sense you guys
are doing proteomics yes on the 6,000
yeah and then what do you guys want to
find with doing metagenomics Studies on
the data researchers would like to link
their microbiota to different disease
also I think is to try to do the
intervention yes of all this disease so
what we want to do is to link the
microbiota to austere policies and to
see because we we have genetic data we
have if we have another other data's we
can I think we can explain moan of these
disease right you have to resist yes
yeah yes so the more you have these
metagenomic data Sproat omics microbiota
or the sex stuff sequenced yeah you can
potentially come in with a intervention
through the microbiome yeah yeah yeah
yeah you can do different interventions
yeah you're interesting to tackle
complex disease yes you're processing
more okay and then what do you think
that you know having these bio banks um
what will be the big thing like if we
have the 30 million reference for the
variants in Chinese and then we do that
for Indian and African and you know your
Europeans already done South America and
blah blah blah you just keep going yeah
what insights are you most excited about
that bringing for Chinese and for all
these other popular
around the world let's the prediction of
disease to do the prediction of the
disease about different for foe for the
specific population yeah if because we
cannot use the genetic data of European
population to predict disease in Chinese
population yeah how much overlap is
there with European population genetics
with Chinese is there you know out of
these variants out of these 30 million
variants yeah how many in fact most of
them are overlapped most overlap yeah
most of them are overlapped but I mean
for the coma warrant most of them are
overlapped for common very yeah for the
rare each each population have their own
unique reg rare genetic variant
interesting and full but I guess
osteoporosis rare yes oh no no no it's
not I know I mean I mean the rare
genetic variant not a disease yeah yeah
Oh rare genetic variants yes most common
genetic variants overlap yeah okay yeah
a rare genetic variants don't over yes
what percentage do you think is common
versus rare the moment beaker of the
population then the mome rare genetic
where we found larger populations have
have more rare genetic wear and more
rare genetic variants yes
what would an ideal tool be like let's
say 50 years
hundred years down the line in the
future hmm what would your ideal tool be
like for doing the most advanced
bioinformatics mm I mean the tools
developed to do the to analyze the
genetic data to analyze genetic data and
then to deal with complex disease yes to
augment humans yeah make us better yeah
what would that to look like fifty or a
hundred years down the line
yeah because the the genetic field moves
fast I think one thing is a prediction
yeah the prediction tools to use
specific population to predict disease
for that specific population yes so I
think this tool can be a good one
predicting disease we have predicting
disease but of course we meet the
reference we need to reference generally
so yeah yeah okay okay so would be maybe
something that's all in one that gets
the genetic data that does the analysis
that predicts the disease gives
recommendations right the whole kind of
this okay okay how do you think we can
inspire more people around the world to
work together if the data can be shared
between research group or research group
within one country or in different
country then
I think that the problem is the data
sharing I think yeah yeah
I like that answer so much we have a big
problem with data silos across the world
across the big tech companies across the
big governments across the medical
institutions and research institutions
etc and so yeah if we can more easily
share data to provide unique insight yes
gentles health into their education into
their well-being right
you know that's exit like let's figure
out how to maximize doing that soon yeah
I like that okay for young people what's
an important skill that they need to
know as we go into the exponential
technology age though young people young
people at which age young people in
general today I don't know if I came
group as a young people let's say those
that are still in the school system yeah
yeah school high school oh yeah sure
okay
I think this question have different
kind of answers in different country or
in with different cultures right because
of Education it is very different
between like China India and the US
right so yeah yeah is there something
that you think China India the US and
other countries around the world do you
think that there's something that young
people can learn that makes them just
stronger for the future mm-hmm the the
basic thing is I think they should well
educated right
I think mm-hmm I agree yeah it's hard to
say what is the best education system
yeah we have a CT SAT Gow cow with all
these yeah systems but what about social
intelligence and what about spiritual
intelligence
what about solving the sustainable
development goals of the United Nations
hmm so it's hard to exactly say what
that is but I'm gonna agree that the
education yeah what do you think is the
meaning of life
oh so this this is another big question
we should make our life more happier we
should let our parents
live better too we shall have a heavy
family to provide good education to our
case if we were overloaded by our daily
life we maybe we have no time to think
about the meaning of life right with
because we don't know the world after we
die right so we should live a bad life
when we are alive also think about our
family of parents let them thing I think
this is exactly why we asked the
question because if we don't think about
why we're here and what the purpose of
this is what my purpose is what is the
nature of this reality that we were in
then we forget these very first
principles yes question yeah right right
and then we just go and just do whatever
why sometimes the economy or sometimes
politics or media whatever get term in
our life instead of right ourselves yes
yeah yeah yeah but in daily life we we
always think about this the politics the
economics that the also the project - I
need to finish right let's if we
overload by out then the little these
kind of things maybe we forgot to think
about the many of life yeah
I appreciated how during the
conversation we were both a little bit
hesitant about the future of genetic
engineering because to be to have this
seventh generation principle so you have
to think about what am i doing right now
and how is it going to affect seven
generations down the line yeah yeah so
that you don't just say do that genetic
edit you know see what happens hope it's
all good so doing like biological
simulations all these types of things to
make sure that what we're doing is gonna
be healthy it's very important um do you
have that mentality that you carry with
you about genetic engineering you're a
little bit more conservative about it
yes I think scientific society they oh I
think they all have conserved attitude
to this question to this yeah to do
genetic editing yeah yeah yeah the I am
starting to feel that more and more it's
important to have open mindedness and a
little bit of liberal Ness to be able to
run the experiments over time
yeah and find out okay the healthy ones
are good that so we can start maybe
implementing those but to be very also
cautious about what could be some of the
long-term effects of incorrect decisions
like can be very bad yes yes what do you
think is the role of love in our world
we care about our parents we care about
a wife we care about that children's
love is everywhere yeah
do you think that this is a simulation I
don't know I don't know how to answer
discussion so yeah what do you think is
the most beautiful thing in the world
[Music]
love why
because because love is everywhere and
love makes us care about this world
about people's around us yeah you know
with that more love we care more about
each other in the world
yes yeah move on thank you so much for
coming onto our side thank you think
that's a pleasure thank you thank you
yeah the incredible discoveries and
thank you again yes it was super looking
forward to all of the next advancements
that you're doing in population genetics
and complex disease mm-hmm thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations with your
friends your families co-workers people
online about population genetics and
about complex disease about all these
other topics that we talked about on the
show about genetics for all about
creating these bio banks in China and in
all these other countries around the
world making better tools for analyzing
these large genetic data sets the
different very variance in genetics that
we were talking about have more
conversations about solving these
complex diseases than living more
healthy and happy lives also support the
artists the entrepreneurs the
organizations the leaders around the
world do you believe and support them
and help them grow you can find all of
our links below so you can get do you
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to beautiful places like Wesley
University and interviewing some of the
great principal investigators here and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world and
we love you very much thank you for
tuning in and we will see you soon
that's a wrap good job good thing
nothing good job okay
[Music]
you
[Music]